foreign
[Music]
piano teacher Carolyn suffers from a
rare genetic disease called stargardt
syndrome first diagnosed when she was
six the condition has progressively led
to a loss of her vision as a classified
rare disease it can be risky for
Caroline to travel abroad when treatment
for the disorder can be difficult
one day I had an allergic reaction to a
very strong product and so I went to
accident an emergency of course they
quickly realized I couldn't see anything
but it was really complicated to explain
everything so that they had all the
information
foreign
although specialists at Strasbourg
University Hospital have been managing
Carolyn's condition these types of
illnesses can be immensely challenging
for doctors due to the low number of
cases but what actually constitutes a
rare disease it's a condition that
affects less than one in two thousand
people more than six thousand differ
rare pathologies have been identified to
date rare diseases currently affect an
estimated 30 million people in Europe
and 300 million worldwide
when it comes to treating these types of
diseases sharing knowledge is key the
new European health data space launched
in May this year aims to do just that in
the case of rare pathologies the
exchange of clinical information
currently takes place via the European
reference Networks
these connect Healthcare Specialists
across Europe allowing them to share
information and treatments
already 97 of people suffering from such
conditions are willing for their Health
Data to be shared
[Music]
arrives at a center which is part of the
network their file will be shared thanks
to a tool called the case patient
management system this patient
management system
this enables a patient's clinical data
to be shared between Experts of a rare
disease and allows them to make
recommendations
in Belgium Ghent University's Medical
Research Center produces a huge volume
of clinical data every day researchers
say this sharing of high quality
information is vital when it comes to
efficient care for patients with rare
diseases
one of the challenges in Europe is the
access to healthcare for rare diseases
if there are good Registries of patients
with rare diseases with international
data sharing and access to these
Registries then this is a unique
treasury because we connect with
clinical experts and also a laboratory
experts also with researchers to come to
the best possible Health Care
in addition to sharing data online
virtual clinics have made it much easier
for experts to share their knowledge
with colleagues across Europe
[Music]
the benefits for patients would be the
very difficult cases are shared and
discussed by International experts from
within the EU and together we obviously
are much more powerful in our knowledge
and much more knowledgeable to finally
provide better care for the patient the
European health data space should
Empower better cross-border access to
medical information and research
creating a Global Knowledge Network and
significantly improving care for
patients with rare diseases
foreign
[Music]